تطرقنا خلال لقائنا اليوم الى ابرز
التطورات الجاريه في المنطقه وعلى راسها
الحرب المستمره منذ ثلاثه اشهر في قطاع
غزه والاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله بكافه
ابعادها السياسيه والامنيه
والانسانيه اكدنا خلال لقائنا على اهميه
الضغط لايقاف القتال ورفع القيود المفروضه
على المساعدات
الانسانيه باعتبار ذلك انتهاكا صارخا
للقانون الدولي
الانساني كما تطرقنا الى ابرز التطورات في
المفاوضات لاطلاق سراح الاسرى والسجناء
وسبل الوصول الى هدنه انسانيه جديه من
شانها حقن دماء المدنيين ورفع المعاناه عن
المدنيين وبحثت ايضا مع معالي الوزير
التطورات على الساحه الاقليميه الاخيره
وخصوصا محاوله منع اتساع رقعه الصراع
والتطورات الخطيره التي تحدث اليوم في
لبنان وسوريا والعراق والبحر الاحمر
وتداعيات ذلك على امن واستقرار
المنطقه طبعا منذ اليوم الاول تمثلت
الجهود القطريه في التواصل عن كثب مع جميع
الشركاء الاقليميين والدوليين بما في ذلك
منظمه الامم المتحده والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه سعيا لخفض التصعيد وحقن الدماء
ومعالجه المسائل الانسانيه بما في ذلك
اطلاق سراح الاسرى والسجناء وايصال
المساعدات العاجله وحتى هذه اللحظه تم
اجلاء اكثر من 280 مريض مصاب الى الدوحه
من قطاع غزه و تم ارسال 59 طائره تحمل
1850 طن من المساعدات الانسانيه تتضمن
مستلزمات ايواء ومواد غذائيه لدعم الشعب
الفلسطيني
الشقيق
طبعا
نحن تعددت لقاءاتنا مع زميلي معالي الوزير
السيد بلينكن منذ احداث السابع من اكتوبر
واكد منذ اليوم الاول على اهميه الوقف
الفوري لاطلاق النار وحقن الدماء وحمايه
المدنيين ومنع اتساع دائره هذا الصراع
ولكن يؤسفنا رغم كافه الجهود الدوليه
والاقليميه للتهدئه وبعد مرور هذه ثلاثه
اشهر من هذه المواجهات لازالت الحرب في
غزه مستمره
وبوتيرة
وعدم التوصل لوقف فوري لاطلاق النار ستكون
هذه الارقام في تزايد مع الايام من المؤلم
اننا وصلنا الى مرحله للاسف اعتدنا فيها
صور الدمار والقتل ومشاهد الكارثه
الانسانيه غير المسبوقه وتحول الاطفال
والنساء والمدنيين من الضحايا لمجرد ارقام
تمر علينا في نشرات
الاخبار يعتبر هذا امتحان كبير لانسان تنا
وتحتم علينا ان نستسلم لتطبيع هذا المشهد
الذي نراه يوميا على شاشات الاخبار فلا
زالت المستشفيات تستهدف ولا زالت المدارس
تقصف ولازال النازحون
يقتلون وايضا لازال تهديد النزوح وارد
وقائم وتهديد قائم بنكب فلسطينيه جديده
ويؤكد على ذلك التصريحات المستفزه التي
ادلى بها بعض الوزراء المتطرفين في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه التي ندينه باشد
العبارات
من المؤسف يعني اننا نرى ايضا ان دائره
الصراع
واشتداد توسع هذه الدائره في تزايد مستمر
ونرى ان يجب احتواء هذه الازمه في اسرع
وقت والوصول الى وقف اطلاق نار في غزه
الذي من شانه ايضا ان يعمل على تهدئه باقي
المناطق في
الاقليم على الرغم من اهميه البحث دائما
عن حلول مستدامه للسلام في المنطقه الا ان
التركيز ينصب الان على وقف القتال
والتاكيد على ان قطاع غزه هي جزء من الارض
الفلسطينيه المحتله التي يجب ان تكون تحت
حكم وقياده فلسطينيه ووحده الشعب
الفلسطيني الشقيق الذي يملك القرار فيها
والتاكيد على انه لا سلام في المنطقه دون
تسويه شامله وعادله وفق قرارات الشرعيه
الدوليه معالي الوزير طبعا نحن نثمن بشكل
كبير علاقاتنا مع الولايات المتحده
ونثمن هذه الشراكه والتعاون المستمر
والمشاورات المستمره فيما بيننا ونشكركم
على دعمكم المستمر
ل جودنا المنصبه حاليا للوصول الى هدنه و
اطلاق سراح الاسرى والسجناء
وايضا دائما نتطلع لان يكون لدور للولايات
المتحده
دور في وضع حد لهذا الصراع ودور ايضا
للوصول الى
حلول مستدامه تمنح الشعب الفلسطيني الشقيق
حقه في دولته ونتطلع ايضا للاستمرار في
التشاور في كافه الملفات المختلفه التي
نعمل فيها بشكل مكثف
مع بلدكم الصديق وايضا الارتقاء بعلاقاتنا
الثنائيه بين البلدين في كافه المجالات
السياسيه والعسكريه والاقتصاديه شكرا لكم
مذ نقوم به منذ البدايه منذ السابعه من
اكتوبر والهجمات الشنيعه ضد
اسرائيل كما ذكرت مضى مضت ثلاث شهور على
هذه الهجمات هذه لحظه تتسم بالتوتر الشهيد
في المنطقه هذا نزاع يمكن ان
ينتشر بسهوله ما يسبب المزيد من المعاناه
وانعدام الامن منذ اليوم الا الاول وضمن
اوليات الاخرى كنا نركز بشكل مكثف على
تجنب اتساع النزاع وهذا هو التركيز
الاساسي الذي تمحورت عليه زياراتي الرابعه
للمنطقه كان هناك ذلك في صلب مناقشاته
بالامس مع رئيس اردوان ورئيس الوزراء مكس
وصباح اليوم مع الملك عبد الله
والاجتماعات التي عقدتها للتو مع الامير
ورئيس الوزراء نحن جميعا يجمعنا التزام
لضمان عدم توسع
النزاع وعلينا
ايضا التزام اخر ان نستخدم نفوذنا
لتجنب
ظهور جبهات جديده في محاوله لتجنب التصعيد
وفتح جبهات جديده
هذا النزاع ليس نزاعا اقليميا فحسب انه
امر يقلق العالم كل ونطبق ذلك ايضا على
هجمات الحوثيين ضد حريه الملاحه في واحد
من اكثر طرق الملاحه الدوليه ازدحاما وهو
الر ان هذه الهجمات اثرت بشكل مباشر على
المواطنين والشحنات والمصالح التجاريه
لاكثر من 40 دوله كما تسببت في تعطيل او
تحويل اكثر من 20% من عمليات الشحن
الدوليه اكثر من 12 شركه شحن قامت بتحويل
الاف السفن باتجاه راس الرجال الصالح مما
تسبب في رفع التكلفه واسابيع من
التاخير وطبعا هذه الكلفه تمرر
الى المواطنين حول العالم سواء في مجال
الطعام والعقود والدواء والمساعدات
الانسانيه الى هذه الهجمات من قبل
الحوثيين تسبب ضررا للشعوب حول
العالم معظمها من افقر الشعوب واكثرها
ضعفا بما في ذلك الشعوب في يمن وفي غزه
لهذا السبب بدات الولايات المتحده عمليه
حراس الرفاهيه بالتعاون مع اكثر من 20
دوله للدفاع عن امن وامان سفن الشحن
التجاري في البحر الاحمر ولهذا السبب ايضا
اكدت اكثر من 12 دوله بوضوح انه لابد من
محاسبه الحوثيين في حال وقوع اي هجمات
مستقبليه سنستمر في الدفاع عن الامن
البحري في المنطقه كجزء من جهدنا الشامل
لمنع ردع المزيد من النزاعات الاقيه وضمان
التدفق الحر للتجاره وهو امر حيو لشعوب
العالم في كل الاجتماعات التي عقدتها في
اليوم الاخرين ناقشنا الجهود الجاريه
لتوفير حمايه افضل وتوصيل مزيد من
المساعده الانسانيه للمدنيين في غزه
واطلاق سراح ما تبقى من
رهائن لقد لعبت قطر دورا اساسيا في
المفاوضات التي ادت الى اطلاق سراح اكثر
من 100 رينه ومنهم ران امريكيين بالتزامن
مع مع التوصل الى هدنه في القتال وهو ما
كناف من مضاعفه حجم تدفقات المساعدات
الانسانيه المدنين في غزه نشعر بالامتنان
العميق لكم ولقيا الامير وجهودكم التي لا
تكل وهي مستمره لتحرير باقي الرهائن
واعد من تبقى من الرهائن
وعائلاتهم بان الولايات المتحده ستعمل بلا
كلل حتى يعودوا هؤلاء الرهائن الى ذويهم
حيث يجب ان
يكونوا لقد حققنا بعض التقدم في زياه
المساعدات الى غزه بما في ذلك فتح معبر
كرما ابو سالم ولكن هذا لا يكفي للوفاء
بالحاجات الماسه
المطلوبه وحتى مع وصول المساعدات الى غزه
فان العوائق التي تحون دون وصولها الى من
يحتاج اليها في رفح لا يزال كثيرا للغايه
كثير من الفلسطينيين يعانون من عدم كفايه
كميات المياه والطعام والدواء والامدادات
الاساسيه الاخرى خاصه الاطفال
منهم نثير مع اسرائيل الحاجه لقيام بكل ما
يمكن لتوصيل المساعدات الانسيه الغزه
وسافعل ذلك عندما اذهب لاسرائيل هذا
الاسبوع ايضا اثرنا اهميه القيام بمزيد
لتجنب الخسائر الفلسطينيه الكثير من
الفلسطينين الابرياء
قتلوا ان الامم
المتحده تلعب دورا لا غنى عنه في توصيل
وتوزيع هذه المساعدات المنقذ للحياه كما
اكد قرار مجلس الامن 272 نحن نرحب بتعيين
سيجرا كارد كمنسق الامم المتحده للشؤون
الانسانيه وعاده الاعمار لقد عملت عن كثب
مع سيجريد عندما قادت بعده الامم المتحده
التي نجحت في ازال ازاله مخزون نظام الاسد
من الاسلحه الكيمياويه واشهد لها مهنيتها
ونهت
وفعاليتها انها تحضن بالدعم الكامل من
الولايات المتحده ونتوقع ان تحضى بتعاون
كامل من كل دول المنطقه هذا الصباح تقابلت
مع موظفي الامم المتحده في برنامج الغذاء
العالمي في احد مخازن توزيع المساعدات في
الاردن وشكرتهم على العمل البطولي الذي
يقومون به مع
غيرهم ل العاملين لتوصيل المساعدات الى
الاطفال والنساء واستطيع ان اقول نفس
الشيء عن عمال المساعدات
الامميه ونحن فخر ان دعمنا لهم فيما
يقومون به من عمل كاكبر دوله مانحه
للمساعدات الانسانيه للشعب
الفلسطيني لقد تحدثت لقد تحدثوا معنا حول
الظروف في غزه حيث يواجه 90% من السكان
نقصا حادا في الغذاء
بدون اي طعام لايام وهذا ما
يمثل
ضررا دائما لا يمكن تغييره بالنسبه
للاطفال مع ان الزياده الفوريه للمساعدات
امر
اساسي لضمان تحسين الامول خاصه في شمال
غزه ومع دخول السع مرحله ذ كثافه اقل في
عملياتها في الشمال يمكن لم التحده ان
تلعب دورا حاسما في الاحتياجات المطلوبه
للسماح للنازحين الفلسطين للعوده الى
منزلهم يجب ان يتمكن المديون الفلسطينيين
من العوده الى ديارهم في اسرع وقت تسمح به
ظروف ولا لا يمكن ولا يجب اجبارهم على
مغادره غزه اننا نرفض التصريحات الصادره
من قبل بعض الوزراء وال المشرعين لاسرائيل
التي تدعو الى اعاده توطين الفلسطيني خارج
غزه غزه هذه التصريحات غير مسؤوله ومثيره
للمشاعر ولا يمكن الا ان تصب تصعب من فرص
توفير مستقبل يقو الفلسطينيون في غزه
عندما لا يكون لحماس سيطره على الامور ولا
يصح من الممكن للجماعات الارهابيه ان تهدد
امن اسرائيل بالطبع ونحن نركز على الاهداف
الانيه لابد ان نعمل على احلال سلام وامن
دائمين ان المتحده رؤيه لتحقيق ذلك من
خلال مقاربه اقليميه توفر الامن لاسرائيل
ودوله الشعب الفلسطيني في اجتماعاتنا في
هذه الرحله ناقشنا ما يمكن لكل دوله ان
تقوم به لتوفير المزيد من التطمينات
والحوافز المطلوبه لبناء مستقبل اكثر امنا
واستقرارا وسلام للمنطقه ما خرجت به من
نقاشات التي جرت حتى الان بما في ذلك
اجتماعاتي هنا مع اصدقائي القطريين هو ان
شركائنا مستعدون لاجراء هذه النقاشات صعبه
واتخاذ القرارات الصعبه الكل له مصلحه في
ايجاد سبيل التقدم الى الامان والكل يدرك
ان علينا ان نعمل هذا هذا هو السبيل
الوحيد ل المضي قدما وهو امر لا يمكن ان
ينتظر اتطلع لاجراء هذه النقاشات مع
المزيد من شركائنا في الايام المقبله
شكرا السؤال الاول لمعالي رئيس الوزراء ا
نرى هناك العديد من التغيرات في المنطقه
او الاستهدافات لابرز القاده في المنطقه
مثل استهداف صالح العاروري في لبنان
استهداف موسوي في في ايران في سوريا
واستهداف قاده ايضا في الداخل الايراني ما
تاثير ذلك على المنطقه عموما وهل له دور
في الوساطه القطريه السؤال
[موسيقى]
الثاني
حمزه وائل الدحو حمزه وا ما
هو
الموقف هل تدين الولايات المتحده استهداف
الصحفيين الابرياء
وما هو موقف الحكومه الامريكيه في هذا
الامر طبعا
بالنسبه السؤال اللي تفضلت فيه بخصوص
التصعيد اللي جالس يحصل في المنطقه احنا
يعني من
البدايه دائما نحذر ان اتساع رقعه الصراع
هي احتماليه وارده جدا وخطر جميع جميعنا
في المنطقه نعيشه و يعني اهميه العمل
سويا يعني جهودنا المشتركه ان تكون منصبه
لايقاف هذه الحرب لمنع هذا الاتساع من انه
اكبر وهذه كانت تركيز جهودنا وايضا اخذ
حيز كبير من محادثاتنا
مع صديقي الوزير
بلينكن الاحداث الاخيره اللي يعني شفناها
شهدناها سواء كان في لبنان او في سوريا هي
احداث يعني للاسف مدانه وفيها انتهاك
لسياده هذه الدول وهناك انتهاكات يعني
احنا قاعدين نشوفها بشكل مستمر ولكن
هدفنا الاسمى اليوم والتركيز عليه هو
ايقاف هذه الحرب
لمنع ان المنطقه تدخل في منحى اخر ومنحى
خطير دوله قطر دائما تسعى من خلال قنوات
التواصل مع كافه الاطراف ل الوصول الى
تهدئه ونعمل بشكل وثيق يعني مع شركانا في
الولايات المتحده والدول الاخرى للوصول
الى هذه التهد كما ذكرت في السابق المفتاح
نرى لهذه المساله هي الوصول لتهدئه في
قطاع غزه ووقف لهذه الحرب وبالتالي نرى ان
سيكون لها انعكاسات ايجابيه في كافه انحاء
المنطقه اشعر باسف
شديد على الخساره التي يمكن لا يمكن
تخيلها الذي يعاني
منها زميلكم
الدحدوح انا
اب ولا استطيع ان
ابدا
في تخيل الفضاء التي يواجها ليست مره
واحده ولكن مرتين
الان هذه ماساه لا يمكن
تخيلها وهذا ينطبق ايضا كما ذكرت على
الكثير من الفلسطينيين الابرياء من النساء
والاطفال
المدنيون ايضا
الصحفيون الفلسطينيون
وغيرهم لجنه حمايه
الصحفيين وجدت ان هناك اكثر من 70 صحفي
قتلوا حتى الان في
غزه صحفي واحد هو اكثر مما يجب القيمه
التي نضعها في عملكم كصحفي في جلب الحقائق
والمعلومات الى
العالم الان اهم من اي وقت مضى لهذا
السبب نحن نضغط على الحاجه ليست فقط من
توصيل المساعدات الانسانيه الىمن يحتاجها
ولكن ان هناك حمايه للشعوب وللناس
من الضرر في المقام الاول ولهذا السبب
ايضا نهايه النزاع وايجاد كما
نقشنا سلام دائم حقيقي حيث يمكن لاسرائيل
الا تخشى تكرار لاحداث السابع من
اكتوبر والرجال والنساء
والاطفال يمكن ان يعيشوا بامن وامان في
غزه وفي الضفه الغربيه
واي مكان يعيشون
فيه السؤال الثاني من الوكاله
الفرنسيه رئيس
الوزراء هل يمكن ان
تعطينها تقرير حول
جهود قطر الوساطه
وافراج عن الرهائن في
غزه
وهل الهجوم ضد السيد
العاروري في بيروت اثر على هذه الوساطه
ونفس الشيء نفس السؤال للسيد بينكن هل
يمكن لواشنطن ان تضغط كما ذكرت
لتبادل لاطلاق الرهائن كما راينا في
نوفمبر
الماضي وهل
الهجوم في بيروت يؤثر على هذه
الجهود شكرا جزيلا فيما يتعلق بالمفاوضات
وهي
جاريه نعم نمر
بتحديات في هذه العمليه
وبالطبع
وجود هجوم ضد احد كبار حماس وقتل احد كبار
حماس هو امر يمكن ان يؤثر على هذه العمليه
المعقده ولكن نحن لا نستسلم ونتحرك الامام
ونستمر في نقاشاتنا مع الاطراف ونحاول ان
نحقق نصل الى اتفاق في في اقرب وقت ممكن
يؤدي الى وقف اطلاق النار
و ومساعدات انسانيه واطلاق سراح
الرحان ليس لدي كثير ان
اضيفه كلما ذكرت اقل تحدثت اقل في هذا
الموضوع كلما كان ذلك افضل نحن نركز بشكل
لا كلل فيه حول اعاده الجميع الى منازلهم
وكان ذلك محور نقاشاتنا هذا المساء
ايضا شكرا
جزيلا سيد
[موسيقى]
الوزير اردت ان اسالك
حول مدى ملائمه
وجود رئيس السيد وزير الدفاع في المستشفى
لمده ايام دون ان يبلغ الرئيس ولا مجلس
الامن القومي ولا احد اخر من الوزراء حسب
ما نعلم خاصه في وقت نائب الوزير كان في
اجازه ورقم ثلاثه في وزاره الدفاع لم يتم
التصوي على تعيينه اثناء حدث حرب هل كنت
تعلم بذلك وما هو
رايك فيما يتعلق بالشفافيه لوزير هام مثل
مثلك تماما السؤال الثاني
يتعلق
بهل المعاناه التي تشعر ب
بها مع الفلسطينيين هل وصلت الى نقطه انت
ذكرت ان 90% من السكان يواجهون نقص في
الغذاء وضرر ربما دائم له
هل هذا
يقرب فيما يسميه المجتمع العربي وقف اطلاق
النار وان هذا لا يمكن استدامته طالما لا
نرى رد من اسرائيل في اجتماعاتك
لتقليل
مستوى الاستهداف والهجمات
الى مستوى
اقرب لوقف اطلاق النار وايضا رئيس
الوزراء انت تحدثت عن البحر الاحمر
والمضاعفات هناك هل تعتقد انه في هذه
اللحظه مع التحذير القوي الذي اطلقته
وزاره الخارجيه وايضا دول اخرى هل
تعتقد ان حان الوقت لعمل عسكري من قبل
التحالف ام تعتقد ان هذا سيساهم فيما تخشى
انه
توسيع للنزاع في المنطقه
شكرا شكرا فيما يتعلق ب الوزير اوستن انا
لم اكن على علم بظروفه طبيه انا تحدثت مع
لويد الاسبوع الماضي قبل هذا الامر وانا
اعلم انه اطلق تصريح او ادلب تصريح حول
هذا الامر كل ما استطيع ان اقوله هو انه
احد
الامتيازات الهامه في مسار عملي منذ اكثر
من 30 عام في الحكومه هو ان اعمل مع
الوزير اوستن
هو زعيم فذ في هذا البلد سواء كان يرتدي
الذ العسكري او الان وهو لا يرتديه وكان
امر ملفت لي ان اخدم
بجواره وانا اتطلع الى تعافيه الكامل
والعمل جنبا الى جنب جنب معه في السنوات
القادمه هو اطلق او ادلى
بتصريح حول هذا الامر وسادى هذا التصريح
يتحدث عن
نفسه لن ادخل في الفرضيات في هذا الامر
يعنيي اقول ردا على الجزء الثاني من
سؤالك كما ذكرت من
قبل انه امر هام
للغايه ان تقوم اسرائيل بالمزيد لحمايه
المدنيين مع
الاخرين وضمان وصول المديد المزيد من
المساعده الانسانيه لمن يحتاج وسيكون هذا
تركيز اساسي في محور محادثاتي عندما اصل
الى
اسرائيل
الحيره التي تشكلها احداث سبتمبر منذ
اليوم الاول الحيره التي تواجهها اي دوله
هو ان تكون ضحيه لواحد من اكثر الهجمات
[موسيقى]
شناعه التي واجهتها عبر تاريخ الذي يمتد
ال 30 سنه كيف نضمن عدم تكرار هذا الامر
مره اخرى اي
دوله عندما واجه ما تواجهه اسرائيل او
واجهته في السابعه من اكتوبر تريد ان تفعل
ذلك ان تضمن عدم تكرار ذلك بمعنى ذلك
التعامل مع التهديد الذي تستمر حمات في ان
تقوم به وكما اوضح زعماء حماس لو اعطوا
الفرصه للقيام بتكرار هذا الامر مره اخرى
سيفعل ذلك مرات ومرات وهذا امر لا يمكن
تقبله لاي دوله سواء كانت اسرائيل او دوله
اخرى وكما اوضحنا ايضا منذ اليوم
الاول من المهم انه عند
التعامل ما هذا التحدي الصعب للغايه ان
نقوم بذلك
بشكل يحمي
المدنيين ووصول المساعدات
للمحتاجين ومع تقلص حجم العمليات هذا
بالتاكيد
سيسهل
من ضمان عدم الاضرار بالمدنيين وايضا وصول
المزيد من المساعدات الى الناس الي
يحتاجون اليها ومن المهم
ايضا مع استمرار تلك المساعدات
ان ان تكون قائمه على اساس
حمايه المدنيين وتوصيل المساعدات وليس
العكس وهذا سيكون جزء من محادثات هذا
الاسبوع
اولا موقف قطر هو واضح تماما فيما يتعلق
بحمايه
حريه الملاحه ما يجري في البحر الامر هو
امر غير مقبول ن نريد ان نرى ذلك وكما
ذكرت هذا امر مؤسف واحد
حقائق ما يجري في المنطقه ونحن نؤمن انه
من المهم الان ان نركز جهودنا على التوصل
الى حل لهذا الوضع العمل العسكري فيما
يتعلق بالسؤال اندري اعتقد انه من وجهه
نظر قطر نحن لا نرى ابدا ان الحل العسكري
هو
الحل نرى الاحداث وما يحدث هناك في البحر
الاحمر ولكن اكبر قلق لنا هو ان يكون هناك
عواقب وتوابع طوال الوقت
تبقين في دائره لن تنتهي ابدا
وستخلق توتر اضافي في
المنطقه نامل ان نرى وقف لما
يجري ضد المدن المدنيه في اقرب وقت ممكن
هذا سيكون هو افضل الحلول
الممكنه السؤال الرابع والاخير من جون
هادسون واشن
بوست شكرا جزيلا السيد الوزير الرئيس
بايدن كان هناك حديث حول وضع الشروط
المساعدات عندما
كان عدد الضحايا اقل بالنصف من العدد
الحالي هل وضع الشروط على الدعم العسكري
هو امر
مستحق
او الحديث عنه وايضا رئيس الوزراء فيما
يتعلق بالتفكير في مرحله غزه بعد الحرب ما
هو دور قطر في مرحله اعاده الاعمار
الولايات المتحده من خرطه في التخطيط
لمرحله ما بعد الحرب
هل هذا
له سلطه اخلاقيه في العالم العربي
جون اي مساعده عسكريه نقدمها لاي دوله بما
في ذلك اسرائيل تاتي
بمتطلبات بما في ذلك ان الاسلحه تستخدم
طبقا للقانون الانساني الدولي وقوانين
الحرب وهذا امر نبحث فيه بشكل مكثف طوال
الوقت ونريد ان نضمن في هذه الحاله كما هو
في الحالات
الاخرى ان اي اسلحه
نقدمها
تستخدم طبقا لهذا الصدد وهذا امر ناخذه
ماخذ الجديه وسنستمر في فعل
ذلك فيما يتعلق
ب مرحله ما بعد الحرب في
غزه اجرينا هذه
النقاشات مع الوزير في هذا الاجتماع وايضا
في الاجتماعات
السابقه نحن
دائما
نرى ان الاولويه بالنسبه لنا اولا وقبل
شيء هي انهاء هذه الحرب وستبقى هذه اولويه
بعد انهاء الحرب وايجاد حل للوضع في غزه
وفي الضفه الغربيه و يمكن الفصل بين
المنطقتين غزه والضفه الغربيه لابد من
التعامل معهما كوحده
واحده هذه سياسه دوله قطر
وستستمر ولن تتاثر بالوضع السياسي
بالتاكيد
ما نريد ان نراه هو حل دائم للشعب
الفلسطيني لتقديم دوله لهم في نهايه
المطاف هذا هو سيكون الطبي